morning John remember back in 2011 when
we launched two YouTube channels scishow
and crash course that are now way bigger
than vlogbrothers and both have over a
billion views on her channels I've been
really glad that we did that for a long
time but what I didn't know is that
those channels and a bunch of other ones
we do like the art assignment and
healthcare triage and scishow kids would
suddenly become more useful during a
pandemic like I didn't think that would
happen because I didn't think there
would be a pandemic I've said this a lot
but the goal of those things isn't to
replace the classroom it's to help
learners and teachers teach and learn
because you can't replace the classroom
but now temporarily we are being forced
a little bit to kind of replace
classrooms for a time and a lot of that
replacement is teaching over live video
doing live streams is something that I
have a little bit of experience with at
making videos something I have a lot of
experience with so with that in mind
here are some tips for how to do good
live stream let's go first
lighting matters more than your camera
this is what I look like on my webcam
with just the normal lights in my office
now I will plug in my light it the
brightest light you can and put it like
a 45 degrees off center from you so it's
running on one side of your face the
other side of your face will be lit
probably by just ambient room light
second thing audio also matters more
than video so talk fairly loud like this
is not my normal speaking voice you can
afford to drop 40 or 50 dollars on a mic
and a light I've put some links in the
descriptions to cheap ones that are good
third fairly basic arrange your screen
so that you are facing toward your
camera you don't have to stare into the
lens the whole time earth the rule of
thirds divide your screen into thirds
horizontally don't have your eyes in the
middle that's weird put them on the
third line why I don't know if
background does matter this might be a
little too busy but don't have nothing
number six all the best live streams
have some kind of audience interaction
even if you aren't interacting with
every single person if you are
interacting with some people it makes
everyone feel like they are being
interacted with especially if no one's
ever sure which person is going to be
the one who is going to be interacting
everybody present and feeling like
they're in the same space together
number seven lag is a thing and it is
avoidable if you say something and
someone doesn't answer immediately
don't start talking because chances are
they will start talking to you shortly
member eight if you can directly wire
your computer via an actual cord to the
internet that will decrease the chances
of something going wrong number nine
this is one to take with a grain of salt
bone I'm doing a live stream I do not
like to script but I do like to outline
I like to know roughly what I'm going to
say but I don't want to know exactly
what I'm gonna say don't want that super
pre-planned energy but you also don't
want that super chaotic I'm not sure
what I'm gonna say next energy number
ten it is totally fine to feel weirded
out by this and to be nervous and not
great at it this is not what you were
hired to do keep at it if you want to
practice while no one's there there's
nothing wrong with that except that your
cat or spouse might think you're going
loony and if you keep doing it it does
get less weird and finally number eleven
use whatever resources are at your
disposal there are lots of teachers
doing this right now
do your best to learn from them to
connect with them to help them and also
the internet is full of great videos
like crash course but all kinds that are
there for you to use and indeed crash
course is launching a video series right
now with Arizona State University called
study hall it's a series of learning
playlists we're gonna look at topics
from writing and Composition to algebra
to chemistry and more important than
ever these days data literacy the first
episode on composition is on the
internet now the goal of study hall is
to help as many people as possible be
successful in their education whether
their current students want to fill some
gaps before going back to school or just
want to learn this is for you and we
wanted to make it free for everyone to
see you can subscribe now at youtube.com
slash ASU John I'll see you on Tuesday